people talk about the steppenwolf design
but they don't talk enough about the
performance and now
karen hines gonna get a chance to really
shine i'm excited for that
what's happening reject nation we got
ourselves a steppenwolf snyder cut
trailer
today here it's got some dark side in it
i'm jealous i got some friends right now
who um
i can't say anything especially
multiple more than one all right it'll
be that much sweeter with the extra
anticipation
all i really care is that i want to get
a screener you know i just wanted a
screener it's all i want to say
you know and some people i know haven't
got a screener but they
got to do other things and some people
got to have a screen everyday and get to
do the other things so i'm going to say
something to say
i'm just a big of a supporter of them so
i'm saying guys
championing this for a long time but not
no you guys but no no no no
jealousy just creates a wall a law of
attraction energy you know like it's
okay
don't worry i'm happy for you guys not
at all bitter
just right now i really connect most
with steppenwolf and darkseid out of any
of the justice league cast that's okay
[Music]
oh
okay so he's a hologram there
atlan oh gods
see the lanterns back there you got zeus
in there you got a whole lot
and it's definitely ryan reynolds guys
everyone shut up we're watching that
again two times let's go
i love that man those pair demons look
so good
no protectors no kryptonians no lanterns
[Applause]
yeah what you failed to do darkseid was
realize
all the superheroes are here
all of them are here pick the wrong
place all of them are here
where's the world full of nobody else
with superheroes
even the martian guys here oh you have
no idea
do you see that you got the amazonians
the atlanteans yeah so you've got the
old gods of
every culture here to meet this ultimate
threat you know which is kind of
watchmen esque in its own way
it's like lord of the rings game of
thrones style like when we're in this
sequence it's just gonna feel like pure
epic dc fantasy come to life
just pure epicness yeah i gotta say too
this has been like a redemption story
for so many people the
zack snyder's justice league gal gadot
he's cool we didn't really feel that
necessary in the justice league version
and here he's going to feel very
necessary but karen hines man
how you say it cheering heinz kieran
hines i
s or siran or siraj kiran
the guy who plays steppenwolf i am so
thrilled
that he has just been getting so much
like
so much of what his performance is
relies so much on what the visual
effects team does
and so for what happened in the justice
league version
and how they made him like the ps2
graphics
just immediately whatever good he
might have been able to do even in that
version of that movie
just completely gets swept under the rug
just because of
his terrible look in cgi here
just these trailers alone he actually
seems scary just these trailers alone he
seems imposing the additional dialogue
that we didn't hear before
that voiceover work or i think it was
was it mocap they believe it was mocap
actually him being here
to really let his performance shine
because he's another one who
especially got undercut oh yeah and the
version years ago and it had to suck for
it
and now for there to be like the
stavenwolf dedicated trailer see him
going trending on twitter see people are
excited about his design
think he's a menacing i just think
that's so awesome i'm so happy for him
absolutely i mean it really makes him
feel like much more of a presence and
two not just the graphics but justice
league seemed to really water down and
just make his
story very rote and very kind of
uninspired and this
looks like something that actually gets
you excited for like oh yeah that's
right like
a lot of people know karen heinz from
being mance raider on on game of thrones
was a great character
different obviously because he wasn't
like as much of an
out-and-out villain as this so then
you're like oh yeah i would love to see
him in this
next step of that because this does
really feel like that epic game of
thrones type feel and also for me
thinking way back i'm like oh it's gonna
be cool too to see in a dc
justice league context zack snyder go
back to something that is kind of akin
to 300 for a minute and revisit
that sort of era and that feel of just
the epic soldiers poet what i've been
loving so much about just what we've
been getting with him is that it feels
like he's got a purpose
the last one was just kind of generic
avenues guy that's how he just got
turned into whereas
here there's so much underneath
everything whether that be
his servitude loyalty to dark side
or uh it sounds like th but the
impression i'm getting is that there's
more of that deeper connection with his
mother hegra inside of the mother box
you know and how that's all gonna link
to the creation of
cyborg this is all just gonna be so much
better and
feels so much more personal yeah that's
something that i think
each one of these trailers has really
been demonstrating even from the dark
side one that we watched the other day
maybe not as much as the other
characters but i feel like with
all these solo justice league players
and even the the
main villain of this installment
steppenwolf even it feels
personal for him now yeah and i love
that that's how you can be on board for
a four-hour journey
when it feels personal for everyone
you're cutting around to
and so yeah i'm really excited for uh
karen hines to get his
his chance again you know like i don't
feel like enough people have been
talking about how he got duped people
talk about the steppenwolf design but
they don't talk enough about the
performance and now
karen hines gonna get a chance to really
shine i'm excited for that all right
guys zack snyder's justice league
did you see it i know who's the only
ones who haven't seen
it it's just everybody but us man i
don't know
multiple zack snyder multiple personal
people multiple
zack snyder was like i love all of my
supporters except these
two guys yeah what are you gonna do man
i feel like i've made my journey
very it's been a redemption art i've
i've been batman in batman v superman i
went from i don't like it too
oh my god oh my god this movie again i
see it in a whole new light i understand
it all now i see for i have been shown
yeah it's like the journey of
re-watching and re-watching and
re-watching and then now i'm like
i'm so in love with this i want to make
a dedicated video
anyway guys subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
check out our other
zack snyder justice league videos as
well
last but not least i want to do a
jt jt was telling me very recently
he started a movie called tom and jerry
and then he only got about 30 minutes
into it
and then eventually turn it off what a
failure on your end dude do you realize
that if you just let it play
you could have watched at least an hour
of zack snyder's justice league
you missed out to be one of the [ __ ]
on the internet who decides to
take footage and screenshot it put it on
oh it's getting taken off twitter
let me put it on tik tok you could have
been one of those people
you could have been banned from several
still would have shouted you out for
some reason
just because it's the way i am no it's a
good thing you turned it off actually
what jt did was it the snyder cut
started playing and then he won
i gotta try this off no way i know uh
snyder cut fans
we are the real judges if we start
playing we would turn it off
absolutely we would all not watch it we
wouldn't freak out and bring as many
people as possible to see whose job is
about to be eliminated for this
we don't stop we don't stop just like jt
did
get on you man
[Music]